[Music]
if you think that it's hard to be a
photographer you're right but don't
think that they always need the perfect
background or the most incredible
special effects what makes them really
good is actually their imagination just
wait until you see how they find nature
in big cities if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we're showing you
ten reasons you shouldn't trust photos
on social media the cliff you've
probably seen this picture before people
are dangerously standing on a cliff or
should we say under it are people really
risking their lives for a picture
actually some people are really ready to
do anything to get a lot of likes that's
why we heard the sad news that people
really did pass away trying to take a
selfie and we would agree that it is
absolutely not
worth it but that's not the case for
everyone as you can find another way to
take an incredible picture like that
sometimes the clip is not that high and
they just use the background to make it
look different do you really think that
this father would risk the life of his
son simply to get more attention on
social media and how did that guy even
get down there hanging upside down we
found the answer to your question in
another picture posted by a tourist as
you can see this lady probably just went
under the fake clip and climbed on it to
take a picture the result is really
impressive but what we liked even more
is the imagination of all the people
taking this kind of picture and we think
that they should get even more attention
than people who are really risking their
lives cheating by using a different
angle is smarter than doing something
dangerous just for likes we can't help
but admire their creativity the snow
don't you think that this photo looks
cute a couple just got married and her
new husband is making sure that she
stays warm as it starts snowing but if
you take a step back you'll realize that
it is not romantic at all
no the photographer didn't just catch a
beautiful moment they're actually posing
and it is not snowing outside either an
assistant is just spitting water out of
his mouth to create that special effect
we can't think of anything less romantic
than someone's spitting on you at your
wedding even though the results look
great we bet that it's something they
don't want their friends to see on
social media and they're not the only
ones doing this this time the assistant
is using his mouth to produce smoke yes
the result looks great but we would be
really uncomfortable if we were the
model posing for the picture at least
the picture looks really pretty no one
could get that the smoke was created
like that and don't worry there are
other ways you can use to produce snow
this time the assistant simply used a
machine to make it appear like it's
snowing in the photo but if you look
down you will also see the bare legs of
the model we guess that it's not really
cold in the studio after all the cars
when photographers want to take pictures
of the best-looking cars do they really
have to buy them even renting them could
cost a lot for a simple picture so what
do they do to get that beautiful result
you just have to look at this picture
from a different angle to see how they
created it it is really difficult to buy
a vintage car but a photographer just
bought a tiny one instead then they
create a fake street next to a house and
use the perfect angle to make it look
like a real scene and they're not the
only one who had a smart idea this
photographer recreated a really
impressive picture with a tiny car you
might think that they had to travel the
world to find the perfect place to do
the photo shoot but all they needed was
a beautiful sky and some accessories but
don't think that makes it easy to be a
photographer because it takes a lot of
skills to make people believe that what
they see is real they also need to be
great artists to just look at what this
man created it probably took a lot of
effort to make it look realistic and we
can't believe that this is what he
photographed not a lot of people can
afford a real car but we think that it
is also rare to find someone who has the
skill to turn a toy into a work of art
the angle as we previously saw you can
make people believe in a lot of things
simply by using the right angle and we
have even more examples to show you this
time the photographers are doing weird
things to get the perfect picture and
when you see the behind the scenes the
results are hilarious
during this photo shoot the photographer
wanted to take a picture of two friends
holding hands but the problem is that he
had to make it look like we were the guy
by doing a POV or a point of view this
is why he decided to jump on the guy and
take a picture in this weird angle no
matter what everyone is smiling so we
bet that they had a lot of fun doing
this in this other picture you can see
that the photographer is about to fall
in the water simply because he wants to
take the perfect picture if it weren't
for his leg keeping him in place the
photo shoot would be ruined no matter
what the final result looks gorgeous so
we think that doing this was worth it
and we have one last picture for you
this time we don't know what the
photographer is looking at but her pose
is really funny to look at we think that
it is probably more interesting than the
picture itself the special effects this
time you won't have any doubt that
photographers are some of the best
artists in the world when you see how
they can transform a picture and know
this is not something that you can do
with a cell phone and a pre
editing app online how do you think that
this photographer took a picture of a
girl in a room full of water don't worry
she wasn't really about to drown and
they just used a lot of Photoshop if you
take a look at the picture before the
modifications you can see that the girl
is actually lying on many pieces of
furniture then the photographer just had
to erase the objects add more blue to
this picture and add some bubbles don't
think that you can do this at home only
a professional can do this here's
another example of a group of kids
working together to make it appear like
one of them is falling from the sky you
would never guess that this was the
original picture another one also wanted
to show his friends that he was able to
fly by lying on different objects and we
have more examples to show you this time
we just needed a guy to hold the model
to make it look like she was floating
they also tried to make her look like
she was flying and we don't even
understand how the guy is holding her
these pictures are just incredible the
position you have to suffer to be
beautiful and it is also true when
you're talking about photography the
weirder it feels the better it looks
just take a look at this model looking
through the window this pose looks
really easy doesn't it do you think that
anyone could do that if you see her
whole body you would understand that she
was probably suffering right now just
look at how she needs to place her legs
to make sure that she was short enough
for the picture we think that she's
doing a great job at pretending that
everything is okay in front of the
camera and she is not the only one in a
strange position this model is posing in
front of the perfect background but
unfortunately she is too tall that's why
she has to squat to make sure that
everything looks the best and just look
at her hair stuck in the tree to make it
appear like they are blown by the wind
it's just weird when you think about it
next is a beautiful couple posing
together but as you can see the woman
has to make herself look shorter when
standing next to her partner this girl
is spreading her legs too and it looks
hilarious and then there's this girl who
needs to make herself look taller so she
sits on another man they should post the
original pictures instead of the final
result it makes us smile even more the
background we would all love to travel
the world and take pictures in the most
beautiful places but don't worry if you
don't have enough money to buy an
airplane ticket you can take amazing
pictures in the comfort of your own home
how can you do that many people dream of
posing in front of the Eiffel Tower and
this girl realized her dream simply with
a printer she printed one big picture on
many pages and created a beautiful
background with it when you look at the
picture it is just like she traveled to
France in a second then there's this
girl who spends an afternoon next to
beautiful mountains while
staying at home she simply used a
projector we could easily do this at
home with any picture and we think that
we'll be trying it tonight
this technique is so popular because of
its amazing results that people started
creating some backgrounds for tourists
if you go to Hong Kong you will notice
that there is too much pollution for you
to see the sky and the city that's why
people can simply pose in front of a
picture of the city to show their
friends that they went on a beautiful
vacation it's sad to think that real
life doesn't look as good as this fake
city but at least tourists can have
beautiful souvenirs the modifications we
all heard about Photoshop but do you
know how far the modifications can go
we're not only talking about erasing a
pimple or making someone thinner the
models can be transported to a whole new
world this picture is probably the
biggest transformation that we have ever
seen a young man surrounded by smoke is
posing with a cloth and what seems to be
a professional studio but if you look at
the original picture it seems like you
could take it in anyone's room the cloth
was actually a very big bowl there was
no smoke at all the man was only wearing
underwear and he was just sitting on a
bed in a messy room it's maybe not the
best picture but we have never seen such
incredible Photoshop skills in the next
picture the model is simply posing with
a piece of plastic and the artist turned
it into something really beautiful it's
like they're in two different worlds but
that's not all you can also see the
bride and groom posing in what seems to
be a beautiful palette but they were
actually just standing in front of a
white bed sheet in a really normal room
that means you don't have to spend a lot
of money if you want to take beautiful
pictures on your honeymoon all you need
is to find someone to transform the
picture with their photoshop skills the
water if you want to impress your
friends you need to take a picture in
the water and for better results the
photographer needs to be in the water
with you as you can see in this picture
at least the photo looks wonderful and
we think that getting a little wet was
totally worth it
but what do you do when you don't live
near a lake you can get beautiful
results like that in your backyard how
can you do this simply by using a kiddie
pool when you look at how this
photographer managed to take this
picture you can understand that not
having enough money is never a reason
not to take beautiful pictures all you
need is a lot of creativity if you don't
believe that it is the best thing to do
you might be surprised to learn that
this is what professional photographers
are doing this time the model is just
lying down in water and what seems to be
an apartment then they added some lights
and this is how they got the awesome
result however we suggest that you don't
try this at home we don't
anyone to drop their camera or their
light in the kiddie pool well the model
is in there so if you want to pose for
these kinds of pictures make sure that
you hire a professional the nature we
all love to see the beauty of nature and
it can turn a normal photo into a
beautiful one however if you live in a
big city it might be difficult to find
more than a sad tree on a street corner
but don't worry that will probably be
enough to take amazing pictures when you
look at this picture of a young woman
you might think that she spent the
afternoon in a field but she was
actually just sitting by the side of the
road where the photographer found some
plans and she's not the only one who
tried that in the next picture a
photographer just put a random leaf in
the face of their model and asked her to
lie on the grass surprisingly the
results are amazing
the assistant also put a branch and
leaves just in front of the models face
when we see the final result we would
think that the photographer was looking
at her through a tree but not at all and
then there's this girl lying under a
bush and the photographer who found a
way to turn it into something amazing if
you want to see one last photo there was
also this guy just facing a potted plant
did you ever use any special trick to
take a picture and post it on social
media don't be shy to tell us what you
did in the comments section down below
we love to know what you think and
that's it for ten reasons you shouldn't
trust photos on social media if you want
to see more stories like this make sure
you watch 10 products you'll never buy
again knowing how they're made thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]